wir hatten fest rente bleibt schwierig
dafür packt die groko jetzt den
kohleausstieg an
ein weiterer gesellschaftlicher
großkonflikt entschärft nach der alten
methode merkel mit massen von geld meine
damen und herren
80 bis 90 milliarden kostet der spass
wahrscheinlich deshalb hat die kanzlerin
auch so fröhlich geguckt als mit den
bericht der kohle kommission überreicht
hat wann welches kraftwerk wirklich
abgeschaltet wird steht nämlich noch gar
nicht fest das heißt der eigentliche
lobby terror fängt jetzt erst an
ganz zu schweigen von diesen kleinen
schulschwänzern die weiter jeden freitag
für klimaschutz demonstrieren
ein ton ein kohleausstieg nach 20 30 ist
für uns keine option ist unsere zukunft
und nicht die der erwachsene menschen
die jetzt auch schon irgendwann sterben
als unverschämtheit oder in sotschi
hallo 2038 da bin ich gerade mal scheiße
der bengel hat recht ja diese schüler
haben in berlin sogar unseren niedlichen
energieminister peter altmaier nieder
gebucht haben es gesehen sein referent
hatte ihn offenbar überredet zur
schülerdemo hinzugehen und das führte zu
einem wunderbar authentischen moment zum
glück von unserer zdf kamera eingefangen
[Applaus]
richtig das war eine scheißidee
ich fürchte dieser referent steht dem
freien arbeitsmarkt bald wieder zur
verfügung haben also der kohleausstieg
ist erst einmal beschlossen wissen sie
also die kleinigkeiten sagen wir mal
dass wie das klären wir später denn zeit
ist fest steht eigentlich nur die vom
kohleausstieg betroffenen bundesländer
und regionen gegen 40 milliarden euro
strukturhilfe und zwar für sachen die
man sich noch überlegt ja ich hätte
gleich mal einen konkreten vorschlag
liebe zuschauer es gibt noch wir haben
nach der guckt rund 20.000 betroffene
kohle kunde wenn wir jeden von denen
jetzt direkt eine million überweisen
dann kostet das nur 20 milliarden statt
40 und das geld dann bei den richtigen
nachteil die sind dann millionäre und
wählen alle fdp aber irgendwas irgendwas
ist halt immer so und was ist jetzt mit
meinem strom wird etwa noch teurer
die kommission empfiehlt uns wenn es
wider erwarten zu höheren preisen kommt
dies nicht auf die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher abzuwälzen
das halte ich für einen durchaus
interessanten gedanken verrückt oder
verrückter gewerke crazy nicht der
stromkunde zahlt sondern der
steuerzahler cool also ja es sei denn
man ist jetzt stromkunde und
steuerzahler aber
das betrifft ja die wenigsten frage
warum machen wir es nicht wie die
engländer die haben einfach co2
besteuert und so den kohleanteil an der
stromversorgung auf 7 prozent reduziert
ohne milliarden entschädigung und wir
kriegen nicht mal ne blöde stromtrasse
gebaut
gerade mal zwölf prozent sind fertig ich
habe nur ein baby aber ich glaube dass
es nicht viel
das bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
energie informiert liebe mitbürger
zugegeben unsere energiewende läuft
gerade so mittel aber gemeinsam kriegen
wir das hin und wenn wir gemeinsam sagen
dann meinen wir euch ja genau dich meine
ich wütend gucken allein ist nicht die
lösung einfach mal anpacken wenn jeder
deutsche für 299 im baumarkt nur ein
verlängerungskabel kauft und wir stecken
die alle zusammen dann ist die blöde
nord-süd-trasse torwarts fertig
energiewende nicht glauben
[Applaus]
es ist wirklich eine tolle show
mal anpacken kurz gesagt es hakt noch
hier und da auf dem weg zum
kohleausstieg in diesem sinne herzlich
willkommen zu
[Musik]
und 7
das kind geben
[Applaus]
ist ja immer geschmacksfrage aber ich
finde unter all den verpackten
großprojekten ragt die energiewende
wirklich noch mal raus viel besser
kannst du es nicht verpacken
da wurde er wirklich alles verpackt sagt
wer auch nur der bundesrechnungshof in
einem aktuellen bericht heißt es die
bundesregierung hat keine übersicht über
die kosten der energiewende
im prinzip müsste peter zwegat sein
flipchart im kabinett aufbau aussage
hier ihr versoffenen aziz ihr könnt euch
überhaupt keine energiewende leisten und
hört auf alles für zigaretten auszugeben
das heißt die keine übersichtlich meiner
allein im wirtschaftsministerium gibt es
34 referate die sich von morgens bis
abends nur mit der energiewende
beschäftigt ja ja ja ja und und der chef
von denen ist auch voll im thema ich
halte windräder für durchaus ästhetisch
und sie haben auch wenn ich durch die
landschaft fahren sie mir anschauen
meistens einen individuellen charakter
es gibt welche die sind sehr eifrig bei
der arbeit andere eher lethargisch dass
er dort machen alles packt an den börsen
ist der strom spottbillig dank
erneuerbarer weil man aber den erzeugern
über 20 jahre feste preise garantiert
wie in der verpackten ddr muss irgendwer
die differenz bezahlen
die großindustrie haben sie befreit also
bleibt nach adam riese nur noch der
dumme deutsche stromkunde ja genau ich
rede von euch hier klein wollte junkies
ihr gierigen ampere stricher das kommt
da worden da sie ihr ständiges robold ja
ich finde es gemein und der staat
kassiert auch noch sieben milliarden
stromsteuer jedes jahr könnte man uns
nicht wenigstens davon was erlassen
nein
[Musik]
nicht mal ein paar cent es ist alles so
spektakulär vertagt worden
vor den erforderlichen 7700 kilometer
netzausbau haben wir bisher wie viel
geschafft 950 ghana und wer kommt der
strom an obis bielefeld leben weiter
südlich überhaupt noch menschen ja wenn
man das leben nennen will also da unten
in süddeutschland die wollen natürlich
auch gar keinen strom dass das sieht man
ja immer wieder alle drei meter rotten
sich wütende stromtrassen gegner
zusammen hier diese frau fast das ganze
elend der verkannten energiewende
zusammen
es ist auch so eine fassungslosigkeit
wie überhaupt jemand darauf kommen kann
solches projekt hier quer durch die
landschaft zu bauen also ich hab dafür
einfach kein verständnis obwohl ich
natürlich verständnis dafür habe dass
das strom irgendwo längen es gebaut
werden muss eben gebaut die blöde trasse
doch einfach irgendwo längst wissen wir
doch der beste ort ist irgendwo der
bundesrechnungshof eine behörde die nach
meinen erkenntnissen tatsächlich rechnen
kann hat der deutschen energiewende eine
glatte 5 - verpasst allein in den
letzten fünf jahren haben wir dafür
mindestens 160 milliarden euro
ausgegeben und verfehlen trotzdem unsere
klimaziele prädikat verkackt ja genau
das hab ich doch ich finde wenn der
bürger für etwas geld bezahlt muss er im
gegenzug auch immer traum qualität
bekommen
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort